le festival BD de buque un
incontournable depuis 20 ans pour les
amateurs du 9em mars scénaristes et
dessinateurs s'y succèdent chaque année
en octobre prochain Parin de l'événement
Luc CIN connu sous le nom d'artiste de
bapème 28 albums du Marsupilami à son
actif un animal imaginaire créé en 1952
par Franquin pour les besoins d'une
histoire de deux autres héros
légendaires Spirou et Fantasio
actuellement c'est avec de jeunes élèves
ivelinois des communes de
l'agglomération de Versailles Grand Parc
que bapè mène un travail de sensibil
l'environnement André Franin était
lui-même très très comment dirait
sensible à l'écologie et moi j'ai
toujours été j'ai toujours été proche de
la nature je faisais du scoutisme et le
marsupidami qui vit en pleine nature et
qui doit défendre son environnement
effectivement depuis je dirais dès la le
3è album même peut-être le deè
essentiellement le trè album qui qui est
mars noir avec Yan nous avons traité
d'écologie ce travail de plusieurs
semaines permettra l'édition d'un agenda
scolaire distribué dans les écoles du
secteur à la rentrée quant au
Marsupilami baptême entend bien lui
assurer une longue vie ses aventures
s'arragent dans les cours de récréation
al la chaba lui a même consacré un film
en
2012 je voudrais exploiter la la forêt
comme un personnage à part entière et
lui faire que ce C cette végétation
cette nature prenne vraiment une part
essentielle dans les histoires et on en
revient à la à l'écologie et c'est pour
ça que marsupinami était le personnage
tout trouvé pour faire ce que nous
sommes en train de faire avec les
enfants et M il faudra à un moment donné
que pour le pas tourner en rond que
cette g prenne peut-être une autre
dimension et comme personnage peut-être
aller depuis une dizaine d'années
maisainant je travaille avec Stéphane
cemand qui a donné une autre orientation
un peu à la série un peu plus magique
vers une forme de chamanisme présent à
Buc les 8 et 9 octobre prochain baptême
ne manquera pas d'échanger avec les
BDFil sur celui qu'il surnomme l'animal
magique à plusieurs reprises j'ai pu
constater que lorsque je vais en
dédicace en séance de dédicace pour
rencontrer les lecteurs très r si si
j'ai la chance d'être sur un stand avec
décoré avec une peluche ou l'autre du
Marsupilami ou constitution de nid ou un
postè ou l'autre les enfants sont
attirés à T enseigne que lorsqu'il Arve
leur tour je leur demande alors c'est
pour toi le dessin qu'est-ce que tu veux
ben si vous pouvez me dessiner le gros
chien jaune là-bas donc ils n'ont jamais
vu ils ne connaissent ni Nève ni d'adant
il n connaissent même pas le don mais il
y a la une magie qui opère cet animal
jaune avec ce ces grands yeux blancs
avec des taches noires cette long queue
évidemment la liste des auteurs présents
au Festival n'a pas encore été dévoilée
l'an passé c'est Nicolas Tabari et son
héros isnogood qui était à
l'honneur